absolutely because the thing about it is
that you if you're on the internet and
you unless you have like a performer
named a director named if you fire wall
of your existence in a way that you
never comes back to your purse because I
know people who have separate Twitter
accounts that no one would ever mattoon
two together that it's town and I
understand why they but it's a real
danger and I think that you depending on
you know I'm a comedian I know I have
there's got to be something online I've
said that is litigating for active
because somebody I do have a whole cat
rapist joke and it's what is offline
it's about yeah movie ideas I pitched my
cat bad movie ideas and so I know that
some people are gonna look at it go oh
that's horrible because i was in
performance art 20 years ago and chain
should clearly um
you got to choose your battles and you
know if you're going to lose your job at
the accounting firm because they don't
want somebody making SNM documentaries
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you're making
then don't but or maybe go to them I
know you know at some point if I'm ever
in the position where I'm filling out a
job application and a resume and
emailing it in and then getting called
into a phone interview and they said hey
you swear on your twitter feed yes I do
we don't like swearing a bird I won't
swear it work well we know we don't
trust you well then don't don't [ __ ]
hire me then sorry click I can't I can't
it's not I don't think it's that this is
not the time to play it safe in my eyes
if you r if you really have a topic that
you really want firewall from your
existence then you better follow our
Facebook Twitter Email your life friend
everything because it's all
whole world is a relational database and
it's only a few connections before come
together we've seen it happen on Twitter
and a bunch of other things plenty of
times of people's political careers and
other careers have come to an end very
very quickly so it's a reality but if
you were if you're playing in that realm
and that's the thing is like the stuff
that we were all doing before YouTube is
sitting on VHS tapes in a garage just
waiting to be digitized it's headed this
way so you did something stupid before
the internet you still might be [ __ ]
regardless so yeah something to think
about but don't think too hard about it
you have to make the choice to PI one
identity from the other because it will
fight them in the Attic rule but yeah
the thing about it is that it's it's
this is about you behaviors that we
weren't you know bullying was people who
have a lead on the Internet as kids and
kids killing themselves because they're
bullied on the internet that wasn't real
that's new behaviors so this idea of
employers having the password to your
Facebook page so they can check you out
it's part of the job and all look like
you really you know if that's the world
you planned then you have
be really aware of it because it's going
to bite you in the ass but if you're a
filmmaker or a storyteller and you need
to be able to speak freely then you've
got to accept that that's part of the
minefield that you're buying into
otherwise you're screwed yeah i mean
that's honestly there's a lot of states
in the country you can get fired for
being gay legally so I would yeah I mean
I think that's the hard thing about it
you know it's like a lot of the
independent authors who were inspired by
the fifty shades of whatever you know
her publishing their own independent
light porn under other names for their
own name you know it's all you know
comments you leave all times like when
the [ __ ] hits the fan you leave a trail
there is a
there's archaeology out on the internet
and it's been building for years and
it's out there somewhere or some cached
page or son saved comments something out
there you do that's really stupid
you